what are you looking forward to
happening next season on the show and
like things like little Easter eggs and
drops this season with characters like
Sabrina yeah I mean actually Sabrina
isn't isn't set in stone yet we don't we
don't really know what's going to happen
with that but I'm really excited
hi rumors Veronica's father is going to
be included in season 2 which is awesome
and we have Mark Consuelos playing that
character which is awesome we all got to
meet him the other day as well he's a
legend but yeah I'm really excited to to
explore a different side of Archie I
think that we haven't really seen yet a
darker side after after Fred gets shot
it kind of shakes things up for him for
sure and I think things start to get
pretty gnarly and we're going to
definitely see that it's like his his
Peter Parker Bruce Wayne moment where he
he is he wants vengeance and he will
desperately go out to find it and that's
that's going to switch something in this
minor and I think we're going to see a
darker side and another thing is for
season two as Riverdale is going to it's
kind of going to separate a little bit
between the north side and the south
side and eventually run is going to
choose a side and yeah we're going to
have honesty I think I believe it's
going to be a big season and I think
there's going to be a lot of stuff that
we're going to be diving into which is
going to be really exciting I can't wait
for you guys to see I can't wait to
start did you always know that you were
working towards that what happened in
that finale and no we actually had a
completely different ending while we
were shooting we all got sent actually
only me and Luke got sent the ending the
night before we actually shot that scene
and we me and Luke sat down we had a
chat about it and we spoke to the
writers and kind of just got it done no
one else actually knew about it except I
said that at that time because it
originated was going to be something
completely different finale what would
it have been if it hadn't been what we
saw and screamy of the week um I'm not
sure if I'm allowed to tell you that so
I'm just not going to say okay even a
little clue ah something to do the
blossoms yeah
I'm still me I'm sure they have common
questions things would come up again
again
about on the characterization is our one
of the most common ones he wouldn't fire
me this weekend be do Veronica is where
I get us all the time and I can't give
an answer to it because it's like if I
do that then the Internet is going to
explode probably I probably get roasted
as off you grow up with the article
itself how does it feel that saying you
don't like a character that's so iconic
ability mm-hmm I actually didn't grow up
with comics ie I wasn't too familiar
with the comics actually when I when I
read the pilot it was the first kind of
Archie moment that I had but my old man
actually grew up with them
so it was it's kind of cool he grew up
in San Juan as well I'm parts Armand
which is it's crazy to know that that
that kind of actually made it made its
way over in the islands which is which
is sick as well but now I wasn't too
familiar with it before I started how do
you feel about to change the course mm
yeah it's good I think it's good that
we're exploring you know a lot of the
characters from the comics and we still
incorporating those iconic aspects as
well like the iconic love triangle and
just diving into these characters on a
more like relatable level I think is
what we're doing
I think obviously there's a lot of
different projects that have a lot of
triangles in them is what is unique
about this one if you talk about working
with a girl and creating yeah I think
the most unique thing about this love
triangle is that it has a history behind
it and it's you know it's been going for
like 75 years and to be able to to play
this character and to be involved in it
as as a it's a responsibility and I
think we all feel me and the girls and
Cole and stuff are really blessed to be
able to take these characters and put
them put them to life for these for
these stands in to do it honestly and to
do it in a way that people are going to
appreciate it as I think our goal weird
question but what it's like working with
some cool thousands of my business I
mean I think you grew up watching like
three like us today I actually watched
his show when I was a kid oh my or me
and my mates what watch the show I used
to love a day and I remember he he
tweeted me before we started in the
pilot
Vancouver he tweets me going like good
luck or something you know and then I
meet him in real life and then yeah we
became mates so it's good you just
realize like because I was coming you
I'm kind of still kind of new to acting
and like meeting I mean I'm not saying I
was like a fan of coal but like meeting
him was kind of another experience that
I've had where you kind of just meet
these people that I hate this word but
like famous and you just realize that
they're just normal normal people and
it's a it kind of opens your eyes --as
but yeah and have that element on screen
looking back on the filming those you
have your favorite months and so that
means that make that smile on your face
living it yeah I don't watch a lot of
the stuff also I haven't watched all of
our stuff yet this dimly some stuff that
I haven't seen just because like I'm not
kind of like glued to it but um yeah
there's definitely certain scenes like
that scene that I did was look for
instance at the end they kind of only
used two seconds of what we actually had
but that that scene was it was a special
team for me and I mean look at like
really close as well which is which was
cool I mean obviously to say you're a
young show there's a lot of different
directions you could go and looking
really long-term with the show and that
particular areas amuse a little musical
but there are other things that you
really like to explore cost the show so
far you'd like to be more of in them
yeah I I think this because of the
history of the show in like the
obviously the thousands of comics that
there aren't stories there's a lot that
we have to draw on and there's a lot of
ideas that can be taken from the comics
and put to life like kind of what we've
been doing but um I don't know I guess I
guess I kind of just leave that up to
the writers I think a weird kept in the
dark as the actors week we kept in the
dark a lot we don't really know what
what's being written until we read it
which is usually like a couple days
before we start shooting like with the
death of Jason blossom we they didn't
tell us anything like that last thing
with Luke we got there the night before
so with we're really we don't have a
clue what's going
all most of the time and if you did do
that musical show what song did you pick
if you had to pick them if I had to pick
them I probably would ever be old Rock
probably be all rock and Steely Dan yeah
I'm selling the looks of the characters
is such a key part of the show you talk
a little bit about keeping getting the
hair right and some of the other
challenges that stems from the other
characters days later yeah
that's gnarly the hair thing is gnarly
the first time we did it I was sitting
in that chair for about 6 7 hours they
were trying to get the tone of it right
and I was hungry and I was just not
happy I was really angry whatever they
said but then they did the eyebrows
which was kind of gnarly as well but we
ended up getting it and they had a
certain formula and the formula has been
passed on to several different
hairdressers that I go and see certain
hotel rooms as well hotel room I've done
it all mate and yeah I don't know I
don't know how girls do it honestly I'm
there doing it two weeks every two weeks
I'm getting my hair bleached and my
eyebrows done there other people in the
salon are looking at me like what's this
guy doing dyeing his eyebrows orange
means you more if it runs for like 20
seasons you will end up losing some I've
just this is the things that I think
about when I go to sleep this is these
are things that I'm worrying about
honestly am I going to have eyebrows
when I'm 25 I just face a remake of
decibels again yeah that'll be say K let
me say a spider-man
butter I've always wanted to play
spider-man
but I think Tom Hollands got that one
wrapped up a but Spiderman was always
the one for me I was like I can just be
spider-man I want to be spider-man in
real life more don't like to plan
yeah when you're playing a character
like this that is so iconic has such a
distinctive look you worry about how
that affects your ability to then go
after more varying things in the short
term 100 percent 100 said that was one
of the things that I kind of was
worrying about when I started the show
was to be typecast but then I you know
it's not really a you should those
aren't really the kind of things that
you should be worrying about as an actor
I mean I'm lucky to be working there's
some there's millions of actors out
there who aren't working in who are on a
constant grind so I should you know I
have nothing but to be thankful for for
the work that I'm doing right now and
I'm I'm blessed to be able to do it
given it's the lucky show would you like
to maybe go and how did you get spots
awesome was there some reason TV shows
and other stuff um I don't know I've
really put too much thought into it I
think at the moment I'm definitely
focusing on Riverdale and what that you
know has to do for me and I don't know
I'll see I'll see where it takes me
there's been a couple conversations
about that I mean floating around about
like what does it call like a yeah
something something to mix it but I mean
for my opinion I reckon we should just
focus on River Delta because we're still
kind of a young show so I think we just
should be focusing on Riverdale for the
time being but maybe in the future maybe
I know there's been talk about like a
musical episode as well something but um
yeah I hope not now who's he who's he
I've always wanted to play spider-man
but I think Tom Hollands got that one
wrapped up a but spider-man was always
the one for me I was like I can just be
spider-man I want to be spider-man in
real life model like to plan
you